Welcome. I'm Andrew Fuller,
season one winner of Netflix's Is It Cake
and to celebrate the
premiere of Wednesday,
I made a Thing cake.
Which one is it?
Is it Thing one or Thing two?
Let's see if the stars of
Wednesday can figure it out.
Welcome to my cake room.
Thank you!
I have made a cake of Thing
and it's your job to
figure out which one it is.
Is it Thing one or is it Thing two?
Wow, how long did it
take you to make it?
Far, far too long.
I'll never do it again.
Okay first of all, my
eyesight is really bad, so.
Perfect.
I mean, if I were to say,
I wouldn't know.
- It looks delicious.
- I was about to say.
Yeah, I just wanna eat it.
Tell me why you think it's one?
It’s bigger.
And, you know, and like it, you know,
cake expands, you know
when you're making it.
Number two does not look too expanding.
The texture. You can see the texture.
Looks like cake.
I'm gonna go two.
Okay. Two.
Noooo!
Now you're making me second guess it.
That's what they do on
Who Wants to be a Millionaire.
They make you second guess yourself.
I have to stay with my answer.
Alright. Time for the big reveal.
Yeah, it's cake!
It's number one!
The show will go on.
Congratulations. You win $100,000.
- For real?
- No.
- Fantastic.
- Thank you so much.
Beautiful. Tasted great.
Bye. I love you. Thank you so much.
I'm dead now. I'm dead. I'm dead.
And no matter what, don't stop baking.
Never. Thank you. Nice to meet you.
Thank you guys.
Thank you Netflix for having
me at the Wednesday premiere.
Truly, this experience for
me, has been unbelievable.
I can't believe I just
cut Thing with Tim Burton.
Ahhh!
My life is over. Cut. It's a wrap.
Thanks for watching.
Check out Wednesday only on Netflix.